hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well after analyzing
and discussing at considerable length
the the tumoral states that are opposed
to each other lack or loss of self
control across iya and self-control or
if you like self mastery and Katya
Aristotle is going to consider it
another state that looks a lot like self
control but it actually isn't let's
remind ourselves what what self control
really consists in for Aristotle Arizona
says that in the in the case of people
who aren't either virtuous or vicious
quite often they will find themselves in
situations where reason practical reason
is telling them one thing urging them
towards certain goods you know making
certain considerations you know we could
say active or operative and desire will
do others and it could be designer in
the sense of desire for for food or
drink or four you know sexual pleasure
or all sorts of other things if you're
interested in the many different ways we
can be a crowd I take a look at some of
the other court had some videos the self
control person through their own choice
follows reason against what at least
some of their desires are you know
urging them towards you might say they
they do have a desire to follow reason
as well they're the ones who by their
choice make that operative now it's
quite possible to you know stick with it
or stand fast which is how we typically
translate this this verb of you know
remaining it in place on that we're
translating here stick with and then aim
it's quite possible to stick with things
you shouldn't stick with Aristotle is
now counseling a kind of in flexibility
as a matter of fact he thinks that if
you're not rightly oriented it's
probably not going to do you much good
to be resolute or self controlled or
hunger however else you want to
translate so some people and he said
stick with their viewpoint their dokes
up there that we know that's what we
want translate his opinion but in this
case it could be you know resolution it
could be whatever we want why because
they're obstinate and he's got this long
great word here is haruka nanase right
which is coming from the word is who's
which means force or strength and then
good almost you know sort of sentiment
idea so these are people who have
strongly held opinions we might say or
strongly held beliefs and they're not
going to budge from them nobody is going
to convince them otherwise this is a
problem especially when it comes to
moral life because you know as aristotle
notes for us we typically get a lot of
things wrong and need to you know learn
through experience and through
consulting others and you know gradually
along
way if we're going to become virtuous
becoming virtuous and then understanding
more of it the person who's stubborn is
essentially setting up a roadblock not
only to change but to any sort of moral
development and Aristotle is going to
say in some respects they're not really
like the self-controlled person they
just appear to be like them they're a
facsimile they are an imitation that
doesn't measure up so what else does he
tell us about these people uses two
terms here which are in many respects
cognitive each other and a little bit
difficult to translate in a way that it
splits them apart on harder persuade do
space noises coming from hate pain or
pitch dose of the words that are used to
mean belief or conviction or persuasion
the art of rhetoric for example is about
creating pissed it's pretty persuasion
so these are people who are hard to
persuade right they're also not easily
persuaded once they've got something in
in their mind Oh Metta peace would not
easily afterwards we could say meta
persuaded so they there you know it
takes a while to get them to believe
something once they believe it they're
going to stick with it even if the
evidence contradicts it even if they can
see negative outcomes typically Arizona
doesn't talk about this but typically
people like this will find ways to sort
of make everything else revolve around
these you know as the French call them
EDX you know fixed ideas that are more
valuable to them than actually being in
touch with the truth so this is not a
person who actually is a Aristotle says
longer of truth whether the theoretical
or the practical sense this is somebody
who's more in love with their own ideas
or with being right or or any of those
sorts of things and Aristotle says that
a person like this as opposed to the
self control person who stands firm at
desire actually stands firm against
reason that is they resist what right
reason tells them and they do engage in
some sort of reasoning process but
they're doing it badly and they are
going along with what wrong reason tells
them right and so they're not proof as
he says they're not able to actually
resist desire what's really motivating
them it is indeed some sort of desire
now it's unfortunate that Aristotle
doesn't tell us much more beyond this
than sort of a typology and that a
little bit about one of these because it
would be very interesting to see what
else he might have to say he talks about
the opinionated the ideo granola
grenoble nice right the stupid was one
way to translate it we could we could
also say uneducated although that that
has a difference from connotation to the
automatics I think there's a difference
between lacking education you know lack
and sort of a cultivation that goes with
it which is more than just information
and being genuinely stupid being and
unable to figure things out because one
is in that sort of mindset and then
there's the the boorish the the people
who are he's discussed in other places
in terms of the virtue that has to do
with social life and amusements but here
he's using anything in a somewhat
different sense so we can't
automatically transpose that now what
does he tell us about about these people
he says the motives of the opinionated
our pleasure in pain what is the
pleasure well they like being right they
like the feeling of being right I think
along with this often goes a sense of
insecurity or fear about being shown up
as as being wrong because they don't
know what they'll do if they actually
turn out to be wrong but he says the
agreeable sense of victory and not being
persuaded to change their minds and the
annoyance of having that
crees of their sovereign will and
pleasure a null thats a fancy way of
saying it cause them pain when they
don't get to do what what is it they
want to do this was IDEO means sort of
singular said it Burton we talk about
somebody being idiosyncratic great
example of this people who talk in ways
that are liable to lead to confusions
right you can point out to them you're
using that word in the wrong way also I
need it this way and you'll say yeah but
that's not what everybody else means by
it and if you keep on using it this way
people are going to misunderstand you so
it doesn't really make any sense for you
to be upset that their misunderstanding
here because you're the one who's
deciding to do things your own way
that's a matter of being opinion stupid
Aristotle doesn't tell us much more
about this or boorish but whether with
the stupid we could imagine people who
just dig in and they're not going to
look at any sort of evidence they may
not in fact be stupid it may be part of
some sort of you know psychological
dynamic so that they don't have to deal
with tension or anxiety or something
like that I saw examples of this with
you know students when I taught
face-to-face who simply would not bring
a text book to class and you know he
would say look the whole point of being
in the classroom and so we can go over
this material together I just so you can
sit back and watch me talk you're
supposed to have a reference point and
some students just simply would not get
it the boorish he doesn't tell us much
more unfortunately about that but it
would be it would be quite nice if he
had I think we can imagine that as
somebody who's you know if we follow the
etymology that while they you know they
can't fit in with other people other
than they're ending up not following
reason and they're following their their
sense of desire and stuff so this is
very important thing to keep in mind
it's not the case that just having
resoluteness for its own sake is a good
thing Aristotle doesn't think so
anything like self mastery or remaining
firm in the face of opposition say
anything would go by the way for his
endurance endurance of pain it has to be
within a context of right practical
reasoning